hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
we're at the Lincoln Memorial on the
National Mall waiting for the Glenn Beck
restoring our honor rally to start later
in the day back and Sarah Palin or among
others are going to be talking we really
don't have any idea what's going on here
from the very beginning of this great
country our faith has driven us to
become the greatest people the world has
ever known but now it seems as darkness
begins to grow again faith is in short
supply
to restore America we must restore
ourselves we must rediscover the values
and principles that the founders
established we must restore the faith
that once guided us that you are here
and we come to you once again asking for
healing for restoration for recovery and
for reconciliation
yes send us by unification all religion
all religions coming together as one
voice in this great country just to let
the government know that then we're
united as is even though we're maybe
different religions were united as one
people in order to change what the
government is doing and in not
representing us we pay their salaries
they need to know who moves the boss why
are you here today well I think that
there's a lot going on that's separating
the country and I think that this was
core about unity this is about everybody
coming together what is the role of
religion in your decision to come here
than anywhere Catholic classic t-shirt
it really didn't have much with my
decision coming here today but it isn't
you know plays a big part in my life and
I know a lot of people here as well
religion is important to you it's
important to people here today
what about Judaism Islam how does that
factor in is that is that okay as well
Judaism this Bible was written by Jews
Islam's it doesn't factor in just
doesn't factor in they're here to kill
us if you're a good if you're a good
Muslim you'll kill Christians you know
as african-americans do you feel welcome
in this crowd or do you feel you know
it's kind of light on
are you a Republican or a Democrat how
many people here in in earshot how many
of you are Republicans how many are
Democrats how many of you are
independent this is fundamentally not a
political rally there's a political
import to it but it's really about
religion and faith and it is about
restoring a lost sense of America the
people here are somewhat inarticulate in
what was lost but they know they want to
gain something back something more
something much more I've been asked to
speak as the mother of a soldier today
we honor those in those distant lands
across this globe where you'll find
silent fields of white markers with the
names of Americans who never came home
look around you
and look to the world past the monuments
where are the heroes today
where are the Washington's the
Jefferson's the Lincoln's of this
generation do you dress like this every
day do you dress like this why are you
dressed in black some because are you
French what's the story behind that
tattoo that's well you think it
significant that's a cylinder of a gun
obviously that's a prison tattoo what
prison okay what what's Obama doing
wrong pretty much everything I don't
agree on anything he's done no bomber
carriers none of that so what do you
want you know what if you could change
one thing you know Monday morning what
would it be
the biggest thing be I think it's
illegal immigration you know I'm a
construction worker I got laid off was
laid off a year and a half it had real
difficult time finding work because of
illegal immigration well how do you feel
about religion in the public square
there should be freedom of speech for
everyone and that is I think one thing
that we do agree with with the folks who
are here for back they certainly are
entitled to assemble and to state their
views and we are entitled to state ours
and that's what's happening today all
right thank you good luck with your back
yeah we were here to restore honor and
stuff and I'll let you know right now
the DC police officers are rude and Dana
freedom for America though all you can
say is that it's a very strange event it
wasn't I what I was certainly expecting
it was not political in any conventional
sense it was more like a religious rally
but a kind of nondenominational up with
people type rally saying that we need to
be religious we need to be honorable we
need to follow the golden rule and that
somehow if we transform ourselves that
will transform the country for reason TV
I'm Nicolas me
you